bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovi deo sono fa vjc sabato e quindi
siamo in un nuovo blog per ricominciare
come al solito come tutte l'ex sacro
santissime volte partiamo che la von
arte della settimana è questa settimana
è stata vinta da antonio che la fa il
celo celo fisicamente sto disegno della
prima volta ea parte i miei capelli
esageratamente sexy o adesso va meglio a
parte i miei capelli fantastici c'è ma
che cazzo di disegno della madonna è c'è
anche c'è anche il cai castoro belize
dei ragazzi è meraviglioso via d'oro in
una maniera che non avete idea vigente
ragazzi questi disegni li ho ricevuti
perché sono andato a fare i firma copie
e allora molti di voi mi hanno portato
nei disegni e cose che tra un po
scarterò quindi è una sorta di scartato
dei pacchi facciamo così tanti ragazzi
dell'ultimo firma coppi mi sono messo a
correre per strada prima di entrare alla
mondadori a firmare i libri volevo
vedere che cosa sarebbe successo quindi
ci ho provato che questo è stato
risultato
[Musica]
[Applauso]
no
perso l'udito da un orecchio
dammi un orecchio bambino vecchio e
stato bello
saluta invece di fare jogging la mattina
faccio questa cosa fa sudare parecchio
soprattutto se sei una persona timida
studi ancora di più questo ve lo
garantisco anche ragazzi passando alle
news non ho praticamente nulla da dire
cosa meravigliosa l'unica roba che
voglio dirvi e preparatevi al prossimo
cazzeggio time io credo che non uscire
più di casa dopo quel video che vedete
vi quindi tenetevi pronti quindi ragazzi
detto può essere che possiamo passare
allo scartato dei pacchi
dio mio da quant'è che non dicevo questa
cazzo di frase chi è bello mi che la
prima volta che lo faccio da tipo
quattro mesi allora io cosa ci quad è
prima cosa c'è un nuovo e tony de allora
perché vorrei che facciano sveglio che
scatta va p se ti appoggio con la
madonna ma grazie love story che ha
meglio di twilight ragazzi meravigliosi
che devo sposare per questa di preciso
delle mentine perché mi puzza il culo e
per finire ragazzi un action figures di
mikasa ed è bellissimo non va bene una
figata
perché chi cos'è sta cosa se un altro
set di baffi ma come ma accanto sono
sexy così e io oggi esco così ragazze
vado fuori sono bellissimi entro stasera
ci sono delle meraviglie c'è poche
parole ancora baffi ma come ma basso
la ragazza che me l'ha dato trovava sexy
barbie si vede pop candy metti in bocca
è e scoppietta figo lo dirò a 1 e 2 che
strano mi cambia moltissimo ei biscotti
mi chiama io ti amo ma chi sei e ti
sposo immediatamente una barretta di
cioccolato cohiba ovviamente coi baffi
perché senza i baffi ragazzi ovviamente
non andava bene da quando ho giocato al
gioco dove c'era toni mica tutto voi
baffi impossibile dare ml è questa non
c'hanno i baffi però grazie tesoro per
avermi fatto venire il diabete orami
fatto esplodere la mascella e per avermi
dato dei baffi sexy più che sexy sembra
un pornoattore degli anni 80 quindi
ragazzi detto vuoi sapere che possiamo
passare al fa vi risponde che anche
questo da un secolo che non lo faccia
risponde già favi file a charlie charlie
celle
spolli chat e non ho mai provato a farsi
prova me proviamoci ai ragazzi ci siamo
allora ho preparato st cagata tra
l'altro nota nella sec saggi né delle
mie calze che qualcosa di incredibile
anche lei il gusto delle case faccio
leggermente cagare proprio questo questo
è un dettaglio indifferente ora iniziamo
a charlie ma li aiuti succede un cazzo
ragazzi che merda charlie charlie bewley
e l'ha detto charlie e devo andare
grazie a francesca rossini fai vedere i
nomi che metti alle foto tue mi facevano
morire quando le ho viste quello che
intendeva questa ragazza incredibile
credo che sia questo c'è prima inter
esasperato esaurito che bella faccia lol
questa questa bellissima mi mordo grande
incazzato proprio c'è volete mettere
incazzato incazzatissimo incazzatissimi
ssimo lol lol nascondino sì perché così
non mi si vede o my dad troppo scary ops
ops mi sono cagato addosso non sa chi 8
pandino lo spiegate paura paura 2 pazzia
non mio dio in pigiama in umbra rating
time quando lo stanno mettendo nel capra
anzi chiarissimo certo diventato ma
spaventato mike è sorpreso
va beh ovvio spaventosi simo stranito
sembra che abbia visto il pene di rocco
direi che posso concludere qui ragazzi
ma manca un museo è così divertente
mario martone fa risponde beviti la tua
pp credi che io non ne sia capace zio mi
stai mettendo la prova
è una roba detti ok quanto figo e adesso
ragazzi cin cin bar
lo faccio per te
la prossima domanda e no vabbè dai vi
spiego perché sennò la gente ma che se
fatta bene era centrata con la roba già
alla buona per potrei suicidarmi
piuttosto che fare una cosa del genere
però che prima di concludere ragazzi
volevo far vedere una mia invenzione che
ho inventato l'altro giorno che è stata
alquanto strana e apprendimento ragazzi
amplifica il suono del telefono per
niente quando fai così
[Applauso]
quindi ragazzi è morta track by favi
genova per questa roba qua la vendo su
ebay 12mila euro vi spiego come fallo
ragazza è una cagata assurda da
praticamente rimangiate i biscotti
oppure del cioccolato con dei baffi dopo
che avete mangiato tanto andate al cesso
andate lì dissenteria ma con la proprio
forte dopo che avete pagato
abbondantemente vite tutta la carta
igienica che avete prendete questa cosa
qua che rimane alla fine della carta
igienica quando avete questa cosa qui ci
attaccate semplicemente un bicchiere a
sinistra un bicchiere a destra e milan
devo smettere di farsi stronzate sarà
stata la pipì comunque ragazzi concluso
che l'episodio ai miei baffi sexy vi
dobbiamo lasciare spero che ai video vi
sia piaciuto come sento se video che se
lasciato momento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come non i video
tra thunder schizzi angeles è jurist i
discreti scivolo prossimo video da
ragazzi